We typically report the results of one-way ANOVA like this. Our F-statistic as
a function of our two degrees of freedom, between and within, our p-value and
eta squared. Note that when we're doing ANOVA by hand, we can't find the exact
p-value. This is the same as with the T test. We only know that our p-value is
less than 0.05, our alpha level, because our f-statistic is greater than the
f-critical value. If we're using software, it'll be the same thing, except we
can calculate the exact p-value. Notice that we've frequently used small
samples in our examples and problem sets. However, we wouldn't normally use
such small samples, especially in real research. But if we use large samples,
we can't do ANOVA by hand. That would just take too long. We would use software
instead. When we use software, we don't care as much about the intermediate
steps. Really, we just want to compare the p-value with alpha. We know that if
p is less than alpha, we'll reject the null. Since using software is so
essential to doing statistical tests, we're going to provide you with some
software output for you to see and analyze, so that you get familiar with it.
This is real data that Doctor Laraway collected from his psychology students at
San Jose State University. There are 188 students total, 90 of which were
freshman, 44 sophomores, 23 juniors, and 31 seniors. And he asked them to
self-report how many days every month they drink caffeine. You can already see
that the number of days that seniors drink caffeine is higher than any of the
others. But it also has a pretty large standard deviation, as does that for
juniors. We want to know if at least one group of college students drinks more
caffeine than the others. Doctor Larawayused the statistical program SPSS to
answer this. Here's his ANOVA table output. According to this, which of the
following would we do?